while lucifer found a stable home on
netflix to air its final three seasons
seasons one through three were plagued
by scheduling changes
fox bounced the devilish procedural
around which understandably led to
confusion among the fans
thankfully co-showrunner joe henderson
and the rest of the show's production
team had a plan
that plan involved weaving the bonus
episodes of lucifer into season 3.
in a 2017 interview with tv line
henderson revealed that the writers were
actually glad they could incorporate
them into the third season
rather than tack them all on at the end
of season two
he said we had a really good feeling
that these four standalone episodes
would be in season three
so we started building them with that in
mind what these episodes do is begin
a new story for our characters
television isn't
nearly as episodic as it once was in the
past many show runners crafted their
shows in such a way that viewers could
drop in and
out of them without missing big chunks
of the plot
while some shows still operate this way
many procedurals tend to have
an underlying mythology for viewers to
follow in the case of lucifer the
writers did an excellent job of
balancing the overarching mythology with
the cases of the week
but it was rare for the show to actually
produce a true standalone episode
that all changed when the extra episodes
of season 2 rolled over into season 3
and as a result the writers got a chance
to get weird in the best way possible
even though the episodes could be
watched in any order they still
connected to the larger character arcs
the writers were working to create
henderson said
what i love about them is that when we
found out we would be doing these we
told warner brothers and fox
we're going to go a little crazy on
these we're going to break format a
little bit
we're going to screw around a little bit
they're very much still our show
but they're like the episodes of the
x-files that were a little strange
goofy or dark very much the show but
flexing a very different muscle
since henderson and his team had an
inkling that the standalone episodes
would be rolled over to season three
they saw an opportunity to use
each outing as a way to not only explore
the characters in depth
but also to launch stories within the
new season for instance
in mr and mrs mazzakin smith maize takes
center stage for a story about espionage
that doubles as an examination of the
demon's capacity for love
that episode ended up feeding into
maze's overall season 3 arc which found
her questioning whether or not she was
truly soulless given how many people she
cared about on earth likewise
off the record was an exploration of the
role lucifer actually plays in sending
humans to hell as he tells linda's ex
humans send themselves to hell with
their guilt and they're the only ones
who keep themselves trapped there
not him so the devil made you do it did
he the alcohol and the drugs the topless
selfies
the choices are on you my dear in that
way this standalone episode
actually holds a huge revelation at
least in terms of lucifer's complicated
relationship with humanity
it's true that viewers could watch these
particular outings in any order and
enjoy them but even though they were
crafted to stand
on their own they each contain a wealth
of character-rich storytelling and
plenty of fiendish twists
lucifer is a show with rich mythology
and that's part of its appeal but the
standalone episodes that rolled over
into season three make an
excellent case for writers being allowed
to stretch their creative muscles
without worrying about advancing the
season-long arc week in and week out
ultimately even though the standalone
episodes were a byproduct of the show's
scheduling woes the end result was four
unique outings that fans
may never have gotten under more stable
circumstances
and given the quality on display it
would have been a shame to see those
fascinating episodes
left on the cutting room floor check out
one of our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite shows are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]